any thoughts about revisiting True Blood
in a movie any updates on season two of
your podcast well we just talked about
season two is back
um I know nothing about any any movie I
love the character I mean if it was well
written sure and I kind of like I'll say
this I it True Blood did not end the way
that I thought it was going to end or
really even wanted it to end I was kind
of like she should go like explore the
world and like become queen of Louisiana
or something like that so I would love
more story for Jessica out of that
Christy I loved the show True Blood but
the crew liked to work with on True
Blood exceptional so I'll say this
it we worked nights it was freezing cold
in Greer Ranch where we shot this show I
mean we're talking below 30 like below
20 some nights and we're out there in
little dresses you know for Louisiana
nights kind of thing uh it was cold it
was long we shot routinely 16 18 hour
days our crew did not have to come and
be there for all seven seasons and we
had a crazy retention rate and that's
because of how professional they were
how good they were also HBO compensating
for that kind of commitment uh well
they're exceptional I mean doing the
podcast now and getting to talk with a
lot of them again and remember what a
special experience that was that's
amazing
foreign